[Music]
joining me now as Ohio Senator JD Vance
I'm a little Tongue Tied because of Nick
Sabin I'm I was in the car coming here
when I got the news about Nick sain
retiring then F was like well what about
Chris Christie I'm like well what about
Nick Savin um your reaction to this news
tonight well it's in Ohio State guy good
news ni s out of here but uh you know on
on on the political front look Chris
Christie was a guy without a
constituency because whatever his
personal grudges against Donald Trump
and of course I'm biased I endorse
Donald Trump I think he made a great
president we'll do so again again the
problem is even if you separate Chris
Christie's feelings about Donald Trump
there is no constituency for an open
borders pro- free trade agenda which is
effectively what Chris Christie was
offering we've had it with that for 40
years the old guard of the Republican
Party offered something it delivered
less Freedom less Prosperity less
security why would we want to go back
and if you want to run in a trump GOP or
any Republican party that's going to
exist for the next 20 or 30 years you've
got to explain what's going on in the
country how do we fix it you can't
pretend we're living in 2004 cuz we're
just not no and he made a promise
tonight Senator um as he was dropping
out watch us I want to promise you this
I going to make sure that in no way do I
enable Donald Trump to ever be president
of the United States
again well he was the first uh to
endorse him in 2016 which I at the time
recommended to him that he do and he did
that
uh and now his promise to his big
constituency is okay I'm going to be
acceptable so maybe I can go on and do
one of these other things which a lot of
these former you know conservatives or
people who called themselves
conservatives tend to do well and Laura
when he says he's going to prevent
Donald Trump from becoming president
that just means you're giving a second
term to Joe Biden we've got 12,000
illegal border crossings a day under
President Joe Biden and Trump is the
threat to the country it's crazy I don't
know what these people have taken where
they don't like what Donald Trump tweets
and so they're going to throw the
country to a I think I think there's a
lot of personal absolutely what it is
but you need to wake up and actually
recognize that the real threat is coming
from an open borders president who's
making the country weaker to China who's
sending billions of dollars of weapons
to overseas conflicts not preserving it
for our own defense Joe Biden is the
threat to American democracy he's the
person we need to defeat if you don't
accept that you shouldn't be running a
Republican primary and I have to say in
the in the Same by the same token and
she has a lot more money and she's
polling you know okay in New Hampshire
now than single digits and one poll uh
against Trump is Nikki Haley that hot
mik moment really was the news because
Christy's smart I mean I don't agree
with him on all these but he's not a
dumb guy I mean I used to watch his old
debates they were fantastic that's the
guy we you know we always wanted back in
National politics but he knows that
Nikki Haley's the Jeb Bush of 20 24 does
he not oh that's exactly right and and
look Nikki Haley's entire strategy we
have to remember Laura it's to convince
enough liberal suburbanites and
Massachusetts to cross over and vote
Republican in the New Hampshire primary
that is the only thing that she's
counting on I don't think that's a
winning strategy in New Hampshire but
it's definitely not a winning strategy
nationally there AR there aren't a whole
lot of liberal suburbanites from
Massachusetts who are voting nationally
in Republican primaries there's no
chance that she can win this primary
it's a waste of time it's a waste of
money all we're doing is making it
easier for Joe Biden to win re-election
we need to unite it behind the nominee
of the party that's going to be Donald
Trump yeah when you add up V and
DeSantis and Trump it's about 86% ofy so
um Senator speaking of trump as a threat
former Attorney General Eric Holder told
USA Today Monday that there would be
incalculable damage to the country if
Trump wins asked if Obama shares that
view holder replied absolutely I don't
think it's a question about that I think
that's what motivates him I think that's
what will continue to motivate him along
with all the private jet travel to to
aahu and Martha's Vineyard uh they're
worried are they not about Trump because
I think this time if he gets in that
swamp will be drained and people are
going to really see what's at the bottom
of that muck in Washington DC and that
is a problem for these people I think
it's exactly right I think the second
Trump Administration will be all the
things that we like about the first
Trump Administration but really on
steroids and I mean that in a good way
Laura these guys are completely out of
their mind Eric Holder the guy who used
the power of the federal government to
attack Catholic nuns instead of stopping
the flow of of drugs and fit andol
across the southern Congress to he
didn't show up to testify it is so
interesting they see Donald Trump as
such a threat I'm glad they see him as a
threat because the guy who uses the
federal government not to protect our
border but to gang up on Catholic nuns
it's a good thing when he doesn't like
Donald Trump I think that that's the
best endorsement Trump could ask for
your message to Senate Republicans on
this quote Raw Deal immigration
nightmare that Langford at are pushing
well look I think we have to be really
really careful here the Democrats are
desperate to get more money for Ukraine
they are actually I think willing to
give us something real On the Border
we've got to make sure we get real
concessions On the Border No Deal
Senator not a rubber fall that trap it
is a trap ask Marco Rubio how it worked
out in 2013 that's exactly it did not
work out well it is a trap and it's a
gift to Biden and I know you're smarter
than that Senator great to see you as
always hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else